overnight
our planet has gone from a pale blue
dot to a glistening white snow globe
stretches of earth have become frozen
wastelands that
are completely inhospitable and billions
of people have been left
unprepared for life below freezing
what changes would our planet undergo
what could we do to combat this global
freezing
and would humanity be stuck on a giant
irreversible snowball this
is what if and here's what would happen
if the earth froze overnight
earth has experienced several ice ages
during these periods ice sheets pulse
outward from the poles and then retract
but three of these freezes between 580
and
750 million years ago
had such an extreme effect that the ice
didn't retract for millions of years
these are known as snowball events
temperatures reached minus 50 degrees
celsius
and the ice and snow reflected light
into space
as more heat was reflected rather than
absorbed by the planet
the temperature kept dropping if you
could have seen
earth from space back then it would have
looked like
a glistening white ball eventually the
earth
thawed you know otherwise you wouldn't
be here watching this video but
if everything froze back again overnight
could you survive
what you can't survive without are high
quality nutrients your body can easily
digest and
let's be honest our diets aren't all
that healthy these days but
ritual our friends and sponsors of this
episode
have just the right multivitamins to
help you fill the gaps in your diet
you won't find any gmos sugars or
artificial colorants in your ritual
multivitamins
and you can always track where your
nutrients came from with rituals one of
a kind
visible supply chain get your
multivitamins delivered to your door
every month with free shipping
and if you don't love ritual within your
first month
they'll refund your first order get key
nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering you 10 off during
your first three months
visit ritual.com science to start your
ritual today
that's ritual.com science
now let's get back to the new frozen
earth
you definitely need a good multivitamin
supply on that planet
okay let's start by looking at what
new kind of planet you'd be stepping
onto
ice sheets one kilometer high would
cover the earth
even in the tropics the ice would be as
thick as 10 meters
most of the oceans would be covered in
ice
only near the equator or areas with lots
of geothermal heat
could liquid water still exist near the
surface
everything would be frigid it would be
so cold
that most of life on earth wouldn't be
able to survive
especially humans people living in
cold climates would have warm clothing
but
this sudden freeze would be life or
death
for billions imagine living somewhere
like
belize namibia or parts of australia
where the temperature
never drops below 15 degrees celsius
if you lived in those areas you'd be at
risk of
death from exposure to the cold the same
would be true
in many other parts of the world
especially for the poor and homeless or
those with inadequate access to housing
all power and energy systems would be
disrupted and
with no electricity billions of people
wouldn't have heating industries would
grind to a halt
even agriculture or livestock
cultivation would be
nearly impossible humans would need to
band together to conserve
food energy and other supplies
you would be ready for living on a giant
snowball
if you were a scientist based on an
arctic research station
at a munson scott station in antarctica
the average temperature is minus 82.8
degrees celsius
scientists near the south pole live in
shelters
built to withstand the cold and ice some
even have gyms greenhouses a movie room
and a sauna
life in a shelter though would be very
confined
you would only go outside for specific
tasks to venture outdoors
you would need layers a lot of layers
scientists at these stations wear nearly
nine kilograms of clothing it takes them
about 10 minutes to get dressed any
exposed skin could be frostbitten in
less than
5 minutes this deep freeze would
also make the earth incredibly dry
as all precipitation would turn to snow
or ice that dry air
could make you feel dizzy you would need
to
constantly thaw snow for water to drink
and the only way to get around would be
with a snowmobile
or if you're looking for a little
recreation
you could try to master kite surfing on
snow dunes
but be careful in earth's lower
latitudes there would be
howling winds this would be another
extreme element
making life difficult researchers
still don't know how the earth thought
from these previous snowball events
unfortunately if we wanted to reverse
the freeze
we might have to change our thinking
about greenhouse gases and
global warming we would need to pump the
atmosphere with
carbon dioxide and methane that means
releasing pure gas or burning even
more fossil fuels on the other hand
we could use bombs to detonate volcanoes
around the world
volcanic activity is likely what warmed
the planet in previous freezes
but these solutions beg the question of
what ecological crises we might create
next
like what if we extinguished the sun
well that's a story for another
what if